senator Sanders thank you for being here
how would you respond to concerns that
your financial status undermines your
authority as someone who has railed
against millionaires and billionaires
okay that's a good question I think it's
a very good question
so for this election cycle we're very
focused on transparency in politics and
the personal finances of everyone
running for president just to see what
their financial conflicts of interest
are how much money they've amassed how
they've amassed it and you know if
there's any hidden secrets in their
finances Elizabeth Warren's career as a
law professor is pretty well known as
something that's informed her policies
in platform but I think a lot of people
would probably be surprised to know that
she has an estimated net worth of twelve
million dollars I mean she essentially
has built up a lot of this just as a
professor she taught at several
different universities it appears that a
lot of that has been just built up from
her time teaching which most people
don't associate with amassing large
amounts of wealth most of her net worth
is retirement accounts that she and her
husband have built up Bernie Sanders
financial status is of particular
interest because he's somebody who has
always said he stands with the 99% and
now has just joined the 1% for decades
Bernie Sanders has been a politician and
he's made six-figure salaries for a long
time in the Senate and lived comfortably
but not super wealthy then the 2016
election happened and he became much
more famous and his earning potential
skyrocketed Bernie Sanders has been very
clear about what his tax plan is tax the
wealthy on the one hand it is true that
he has leveraged you know his fame for
for millions of dollars and that is
certainly a
very capitalistic maneuver but on the
other hand his tax policies may end up
affecting him very soon is his net worth
is two and a half million dollars and if
his estate rises to three and a half
million dollars you know he Bernie
Sanders taxman of applying to Bernie
Sanders I think it's important for
everyone to be aware of the personal
finances of the candidate that they're
thinking about voting for and how that
reflects what they're proposing on their
platform
you